oh okay very very ambient it's um
Spanish oh it's Spanish yeah I feel like
this girl is down for a good time you
know what I mean she seems like a very
adventurous person this is also very
very chill this girl's got attitude I
don't know if you're ready for her bro I
don't know if you're ready for her she
knows when to slow it
down okay this one's more acoustic she
likes to go out and party with her with
her friends but not like in a I'm out
till 5:00 in the morning no I'm thinking
more like she's going to be hanging out
with her girls I also get the feeling
that she might eat you up bro this is
more like I'm hearing drums like Han
Zimmer but at the same time the way
she's singing it is very very sensual
it's like oh
Ray she knows what she wants if she
knows what she wants that's very
attractive you know what I mean I feel
like it's that she has her own like
independent personality which I really
like